As the program runs, it will be building
up internal data stores for keeping
track of all the variables that are
available to different function objects.
And I'm going to picture that
stuff over here on the right.
This will be a diagram or
a picture of our in-memory system.
Since each new run of
a function is supposed
to operate in complete isolation
from all the previous runs,
a new execution context should be
created every time you run a function.
Thus, for each lexical scope
there may be many in-memory
scopes created during execution,
or there may be none.
It all depends on how many times you
run a given function in your code.
To examine execution contexts,
we'll need to actually run this program.
So let's simulate that here.
The yellow arrow will point
to the position in the code
where our simulated interpreter has
reached, sort of like a debugger.
Before this first line of code even
runs, the interpreter will start out
by setting up an execution
environment for you.
The first step will be to create
an in-memory global scope context
to hold all of the global variables.
So let's visualize that
execution context data store
off to the right here.
We'll use a similar color as the lexical
scope region that it relates to.
Here, our interpreter is building up
a storage system for the global scope.
The yellow border is around the
interpreter's current execution context.
That is to say,
whichever one the interpreter
starts its variable lookups in.
So far, the global context
is the only one that exists.
So of course, it's the current scope.
As the first line of code runs,
the interpreter builds up a new key
value mapping inside of the execution
context, in order to keep track of the
value that is bound to the name, hero.
The aHero function randomly
generated the value Gal,
which will be stored
in the hero variable.
Like the line above it, this line
implies a simple assignment operation.
Now the value being assigned is
a function that spans several lines.
But the interpreter's going to ignore
all the red and the blue code for now.
They will only get run when
the function is actually called.
So, that line of code has the effect
of adding a new key value pair
to our global scope context.